hello and welcome to this react to
toriel where we're going to be looking
at creating a application that calls the
half can use API so this is the
application we're going to be Korean it
essentially loads in the new stories one
by one is 500 in the API the API will
return as a list of story IDs and then
we're going to call another API root
that will give us the stories we're
gonna be looking at infinite scroll in
this so we can continuously scroll down
and each time it is that we're gonna hit
the API again for another 20 or 30
stories and then what we're going to be
looking at is we gotta be testing this
with react testing library we're going
to be using style components not too
extensively but we're gonna be using
them just to show you how to get started
with them and we're gonna be looking at
things like memo and react so we're not
having to recall while rerender the
component each time on each particular
in scroll so in terms of this tutorial
and you know what exposure to react you
have to have I'd say that you could come
in this from a beginner standpoint and
if you have a little bit of JavaScript
experience and you have the ability and
nice to call API is you will follow this
tutorial and do quite well I don't
believe there's many necessary other
aspects that you're going to have to
need essentially all this is is we're
now one component which is a story and
we're going to have a container for the
entire of the stories so let's begin and
we're gonna start by just creating a
great react up with happy news tips so
I'm going to take this one the bit
slower than my last one which was a
todoist one even though that was a seven
hour tutorial but this one's going to be
focusing on more of the beginner aspects
of react even though we are going to be
throwing stuff in there like memmer so
if we just create a react up and that
will take a few
seconds you were using MPX here I
basically just grabbed this off the
github of crate right up so if you run
this line right here we'll get a react
up ready to go and we can start
modifying it and playing around adding
components in the only aspects that make
it into the intermediate aspect of
JavaScript and and all that good stuff
is the infinite scroll but I wouldn't
worry too much about that let's focus
mainly on react here so that should be
done now so if we do I'll CD into this
and it was I can use chopped now we are
now up and up and if you want to do this
you can go into vs card and I think if
you got to the settings so I think it's
command shift P and then type tough and
it should add cards your path so here we
are that's good let's open this we'll
start by doing a quick cleanup so
generally what I do each time I get one
of these I go in here we don't need the
manifest actually we can probably leave
the manifest in next we're going to be
looking at stuff like service workers
and I'll explain those downline don't
need a description I'm sure it's just
the description let me make this bigger
so you can see this hopefully that's a
bit better and will sir here well just
put in some content so when you're
searching in google this description is
in the little description descriptive
box below the title so sir bringing you
the finest news since 2019 favicon hmm
don't need theme color we'll keep in now
or keep the description ipod touch
that's just the log off the apple touch
icon if you want to make it an
application or changes to news reader
and my fault process with this
particular application is we
create it now in the aspects of do you
know the beginner showing your heart of
Emery in to react giving you some nice
little tips here in there like member
star components test in so you should
get on your feet with react through this
tutorial then the next one we're going
to consolidate a bunch of api's so we'll
get hacking usable maybe I'll get some
stuff from the BBC or we check websites
and then what we're going to do we're
going to use graph QL on the back end or
just say as middleware to call some
services those services being API routes
and consolidate those and give us those
new stories back to the front-end so
that should be really nice to do and
that's where we'll get into a bit more
the intermedia aspects of reality and
graph QL and we're going to be right in
all our resolvers and everything else
without using anything like Prisma so
we'll just got rid of those so we can
start by doing a bit clean up in here so
generally as if you followed my
tutorials in the past you know that I'll
come in here and I'll wipe out the
majority of stuff so we'll just set
expert Const bring that into an era
function and then down here we'll just
we don't need the return we can just get
rid of that set hello we don't need to
default expert here because we've got an
inline expert here that should give us
something to play with let's get rid of
index yes yes we don't need the logo
number and whilst we're here we can turn
on the serviceworker don't worry too
much about this at the moment but what
I'll explain serviceworkers as we get to
that particular point remove this and
why generally like to do I just instead
of calling react on
here directly I like to just remove that
and just say give me render and then we
can get rid of we need to scene as
though this is no longer a default
import we need to change this because if
you remember it here we're now using a
named X bar so we need to use an named
import here service work is fine there
one thing we have to do to turn the
linter on go into your package GS on and
I generally just remove the es link
configs I like to run the Airbnb one so
as you see it's now running give that a
serve going here just add a equals
remove that yeah if you want to
unregistered a comment open up the
sidebar so now let's have a look do we
need the test not right now we can test
that somewhere else
close down public we've got up dot CSS
don't need that either abusing style
components and there we are we've got up
cleans that up and next what we're going
to do we'll start creating a scaffold in
sort of things like the folders and this
is a really important part of software
development I want you to get in the
into the routine of creating these
folders where you have separations of
concerns so you have components folder
containers folder hooks folder selectors
mappers all this stuff that transforms
your data and keeps it separate so it
can live by itself so I'll show you that
right now
ok so one thing I've just set up now is
well what we want to do let's just begin
and start this and just make sure we've
got something coming out generally you
may see this issue where it's like
telling it telling you about a skip
preflight check there is so if you do
see that issue go ahead in here and just
create a new file and
put light now and then if we go ahead
and restart that we should to get the
application starting well I see come on
there we go perfect so let's begin by
doing scaffolding for the app so let's
do components which is a folder or just
house our components we will then have
constants and generally this stuff is in
most large applications because you want
separation of concerns stuff can live by
itself
hooks we're going to need a services
folder but the API calls a Styles folder
for our Styles utilities folder which
will basically just house stuff that is
kind of miscellaneous mappers selectors
and that should be it for now
even all new containers let's do a
contour in this folder so that should be
good so let's begin like what do we need
to you know start hitting the API
well let's have a look so a github and
then what we want to look for is the
hacker news API so this is a half can
use API and it just gives you myself a
look
these this is happy news and we'll
discover colonists FBI and they've got
this API here we'd have to worry about
all this particular stuff right now and
if we click on one of these you can see
that I returned to some Jess in there
with like the tie or the star in the URL
but like I said we have to worry about
right at this moment what we want to
worry about here is this new top and
best stories so up to 500 top and new
stories are available at top stories
news new stories and best stories we're
going to be one in to hit the new
stories so we need some sort of service
that can hit this new stories so as we
can see it returns IDs and these IDs of
story IDs and what we want to do without
these IDs is get them back and it's
gonna give us 500 so we gotta be a bit
careful in terms of how we're going to
manage these FBI calls but what we want
to do is we're going to get these 500
back and we want to render 20 offer of
them per scroll so to begin with we're
gonna get the 500 stories from the FBI
which is this so this is the URL going
to be calling with Axios and then say
we've got this one here to 906 six two
six five five we want to go ahead and it
says for example a sorry lives here so
if we change this item to this URL
you'll get all this data and that's
pretty much all we're going to be doing
so we're going to do two FBI calls well
two routes we've got to create two
service container routes and we're going
to be calling this FBI Paula stories
because we only need to call this one
this API root once because we only need
all the new story IDs this case it's top
stories but you can do that new stories
and we'll get all the ideas and make API
calls to with these IDs to get the story
so that yeah that's pretty much it
really I guess what we need to do next
is let's have a look when you create a
new tab in here bigger and one's going
to do yarn art Axios an ax EOS is a nice
little package it's not react specific
but it's a nice package it allows us to
do API calls and essentially it's just
what fetch is doing but people seem to
prefer it I like the package you can
have a look just do get her back see
awesome there's tons of useful methods
in there so now we've got actually us we
can actually start making calls so if we
go back in here I mentioned the services
folder earlier lets Krita Firelands call
it hit Chan for how can you use API Oh
Jason with Jason KS and we'll import
Axios from Axios and then what we'll do
we want to create some sort of base URL
that we're going to be hitting so if we
do X book Const base URL let's leave it
empty for now and then we're going to do
expert Const new stories URL let's put
that to an hour and then we're going to
do expert cons story URL and we'll build
these up so for example I'm going to
make these into temp template strings we
want to include the base URL here so
base URL and then Y imagine that one
will be is new stories so you could
switch this out if you if you want it to
not be adjacent and pretty much the 78th
base URL and we're going to say I am
slush so let's go get the best URL so
the [ __ ] you are el is this here right
up to there and you see I've got item
there that corresponds with this one
here so if I just paste that in here now
this is saying this story URL is saying
this particular string lives in here and
then item
likewise with this one
so now we can start creating a function
that will get me a story so let's test
this so actually you know let's get the
story our story URLs first or story IDs
so Expo cons because we're gonna be
using this throughout our application so
we want to import it
so say get story IDs and nut name is
perfect something like that is exactly
what you want and this is making some
sort of side effect so when you think of
stuff like image processing so if you're
on swear you upload an image our first
book and you can crop the photos it's
quite heavy
likewise with Network calls which is
what we're doing here likewise we've
accessing the file system it's going to
block say the rendering of the UI so we
have to use a sink here and by saying a
sink we're going to shove it onto
something called the micro task queue I
don't want to get too deep into exactly
what the micro task queue is right now
but I'll tell you how it works when we
call this so if we do const result and
we're going to say we're this response
from Axios and we're gonna this is going
to be a get and if you look at actually
OSH you've got all these different
methods so you can help delete get
should be passed to patch put requests
so there's all these methods but we're
gonna use a get we're gonna said go get
me that they're new stories URL and what
we're gonna say then is once you've gone
and got me this then get me the data and
we're going to call this data and once
you have that dere just return it and we
don't need this actually so I just said
okay now you've got data passed me
return me that data I'm gonna say return
result and if I just go ahead now I'm
going to up let's start bringing some
things in here so we can test it
oh yeah sorry not up let's close that
down open this up
actually you know what we can test it we
can test this directly nup it'll give us
a good understanding of why we want in
up we just want up to call one Conte and
there are one component and then go do
all the business that you have to do in
that particular file but right now let's
just call in here sorcerer return hello
but in here we want to use something
from react called use effects in
addition we also want to use state so if
I now just say in here when this
application you know gets mounted to the
page as in you can see what's on the
page we want to call our API immediately
but we don't want to be blocking the UI
so we still want we still want the UI to
be interactive so what we're going to do
to mitigate that issue is we're gonna
hold something in a value so we're gonna
say you stir if you've not come across
hooks in react just yet let's just say
we want the story IDs to be stored in
this variable here so story IDs and if I
even want to change story IDs I'm gonna
have to use this one here so I'll set
story IDs so you've got value and you've
got a setter which is essentially
function that you can pass data and we
know this is coming back as in a rear
because if I hit this here there's an
example here you see the areia but just
for some Sun here let's have a look
there you are you got in the rear so I'm
just going to say okay if nothing comes
back or initialize this particular
variable here story IDs soon as you this
loads I want you to assign an empty
arete to it so for example if we don't
have the data and we start looping over
that and it's not in the rear we're
going to get some sort of error and we
don't want that so we're just gonna say
give me initialize that particular bit
up there
we've an emptier so just to recap we
have a variable here that's going to be
initialized to the empty area and if we
ever want to change this we just call
set story ideas so this is where the
magic comes in now so we've done the
work in this hacker news API we've got
this we're making a call out to the
happy news API we're using Axios so we
want to call this in here and we can see
that it's a named expert so we're gonna
have to use a named import to grab this
from the hacker news API so let's go
ahead and set imp and I'll say what did
I call this get story IDs and we know
we're gonna have to go out the side the
folder and we're gonna say God get me
services was just services hitch and API
serve that then we're going to use
effect okay so this is where the big one
comes in what exactly is use effect
we've looked at you steer way of can
stall values so like this is stored to
this initial array to begin with but if
somewhere in my render or somewhere in
this use effect I want to update this
value story IDs I can call this and say
set story IDs hollow so there we are
that will now be hello oops so let's
just see what happens here so if I log
out hello so if you want to call story
IDs you can just search story IDs let's
see what happens here cannot resolve how
can use module let's take a look what's
going on services how can use FBI let's
see
services get story IDs to start right
I did that seems right it's so let's
have a look what's going on and this is
what you're going to be running in so if
you are a new program and you think
these tutorials always go fine I see
people programming I'll just get rid of
that a second and you think you know how
can they get through that so easily
it's never the case stuff always goes
wrong and I think it's best to keep
somewhat of it in tutorial so says story
idea is to her lower so there we are
we've got hello there oh yeah so what
happens if I wanted to change this so if
I just get rid of this and I'll still
you know print out what do you think
that's gonna be it's just going to be
neffeteria and you can let's have a look
or stringify this and no yeah it's an
empty area so that allows us to have
some sanity check so if I just bring
back in import get story IDs from
services I can use API and then say for
example I want to call this method now
that we've put together we've done all
the work in here I just want to call
this now so I can just simply because
it's a beat has been employed up here I
can just say guess sorry IDs like sir
but what we got to do oops put in
outside the well several days just yet
but I'll tell you in a second just have
a look bubble law I cannot find services
can't resolve services let's take a look
so we've run into the same error as
before so I'm thinking that it is well
it's not very descriptive is this where
you are doing X Box Const get story
ideas return result and we're getting
that from
the huh canoes API so module not found
cannot resolve in how can use suits so
even though it's coming through here and
it's all looking fine the modules fine
so I don't know if this is a case of let
me restart this starting it's taking its
time that's fine so it works I don't
know what the issue was there so yeah
we've got the story IDs and if I let me
log this out because I want to make a
few important notes about what's going
on there so you see says promise but you
know I thought it was returning me my
debtor you see the status is resolved
the value and we've got a bunch of dirt
starting there from the FBI says five
hundred IDs in as you can see there but
why is that happening well you see how
we've stuck this async on here so any
function that you stick in a sink on
will always return a promise so now what
we have to do we have to go back to a PS
and say we can't just call this directly
that like we just did then like a
regular function we have to say okay
once the debt is there you see I was
giving me these options so st. attaches
call box for the resolution and or
rejection of the promise so I'm gonna
say okay good get me those IDs and then
return me the result which will be a
promise with the dear are held in there
and we have to resolve that promise so
we can sir and to resolve it we can just
set then and by saying then on this
particular return promise here because
it says synchronous remember it's
asynchronous and the big note is like I
just mentioned it always returns a
promise so you say get story ideas
then we go say okay give me the data and
this could be anything I could say
lemons so once you have the lemons go
ahead and set story IDs and by calling
set story IDs here we're gonna replace
this empty initialized arere with our
500 story IDs
how cool is that so let's take a look
set story IDs with lemons like I said
you can call or anything
well I'll change you obviously but you
know born what's going on here object
not great that's perfect so when you do
see this objects are not valid as react
children we know it's well I know it's
worked and I'll show you why in a second
and why that happens because you have to
get used to reading these errors boom
you see that so you initialize it you
initialize it quick it's an empty area
and then it returns you all this data
but you have some issues here right so
this is saying it's giving me all the
data back from Axios and I don't want
that so let me go back and say okay so
we've got well what we got here we've
got our lemons so we're getting the
story IDs and we're saying dot then now
it's saying it'll set here so
unfulfilled once you have the lemons you
know you can return the lemons if you
like but what I actually want to do you
know I know the lemons are going to be
there so can just remove that so I'm
going to say get me the story IDs over
here I'm going to call this I know it's
asynchronous because I put asynchronous
there thus being asynchronous is going
to always return me a promise and in
there you have promise value which will
be holding your data because we did it
here we've got the returned at once this
is done go back so we're aware in this
context here so it's going to where this
response then it's going to pop it into
result and then we call it then we're
going to set dot then
give me the lemons set the story IDs two
lemons let's have a look what's going on
here so we're getting all this data back
so let me just take a quick look at this
you can inspect it so you've got all
these story IDs as you can see we've got
five hundred and they all we also get
returned the the response and a few
other things from the hacker news API
but like I said we don't want those
better what we want is a clean a cleaner
air so I saw the look so we've got the
result we're awaiting the result
actually us get new story URL then
they're there so I don't know if you can
see the error here was not a particular
error but it's kind of a clean up
Axios is returning me something called
there or I'm assigning it to their Oh in
this case actually is returning media
ACC there well I only want the data I
don't want all this other stuff here
like the content type header is none of
that none of that nonsense
so a way to do this is I know that's
called there because I just saw it in
the console and I want to destructure
that I'll and a nice easy clean way to
do this open up one of these one of
these curly braces
I always forget the name then another
curly brace or sure to say and bracket
up and up the bracket give it a curly
brace and then you know best of all what
create is this and what that saying is
the structure me out theater I only want
data as in that particular value as you
see now nice and clean and if you look
into the the dev tools all you've got in
here is just all the 500 top stories IDs
and if you call one of these you'll get
the article not the article itself but
you get like the title the link all that
good stuff so it's got back so now we've
got lemons and I've shown you can call
it anything let's replace that we'd get
just someone don't come in and think all
right you know some guy here is getting
some lemons from a hacker news FBI which
is a bit strange
so I want to just take a quick a quick
look now I use effect and we'll start
basically we'll start refactoring this
putting it into its own container
because this is far to help the far too
high up the reactor eater we're doing
all this rerender and if you leave
something in app that has access
re-rendering components down the line
you don't be rerender in 500 components
or all the components below so we're
going to put it into something else
but now we've use effect you'll notice
you've got this use effect function here
that I'm returning
well it's saying okay I've got an
anonymous function and go ahead and do
this and people may be asking oh why
have you got a near sink stuck on here
because you know this is you know it's
network call well there's no reason to
use an air sink here because what we're
doing here is this is returning me a
promise so it's still sat on this little
queue called the micro a task queue and
once I resolve that it's going to get
popped off that queue and get whipped
around the event loop and say healthcare
pop me back in so there's no need to see
sticking air sink on there hopefully
that makes sense because we've already
done the air sink here we get return to
promise all we've got to do then is just
resolve it and that's what we've done
there you can obviously put other stuff
on there like catch you could wrap this
in a try-catch or you could put an error
on there whatever it may be but we're
just using nan we're just saying resolve
this give me the data once the data's
here I'm gonna set it and not see it was
certainly done with you that's it we're
done but let's go back to this here so
what are what is this empty array
essentially in the shoes effect like
what why is it just stuck around here
can't work out just be like this well
this is a life cycle if you were prior
to you know hooks using react prior to
hooks you'll know that you had life
cycle methods in react and basically
what this is saying it's saying okay
when the component mounts do this if I
put in there let's say for example we
had a variables like story
IDs updated and what it just bit a
little true or false we could keep watch
on this so I could put story IDs updated
in here and basically they use effect
we'll watch for this to change so if I
passed maybe a set timeouts or set
timeout which I'd never do but if I
every ten seconds even though this is
never accurate in terms of the reading
of the seconds it's basically saying do
this for a minimum of that amount of
seconds so if you have two files and
milliseconds it's saying do this for a
minimum of 2,000 milliseconds but let's
say for example in here every 2,000
milliseconds I you know did story ideas
of da da quarter true and then I'd you
know eventually kept switching it
between true and false this use effect
we'll see that and then it'll be like
okay well this story IDs updated has
changed I need to rerun this again and
when it reruns that it will do rerender
and you know potentially we could have a
new story IDs so it could get a new
story so we could have a live feed of
new stories so all that does is we've an
empty array is just going to run just
the ones it sticks something in there
it's gonna watch that particular
variable and if that variable changes is
going to re-render so you can run into
an infinite loop here if you're not
careful and I'll show you why so well
whilst this is happening I'll just use
effect here so let's just watch how it
works you know if you want to learn
react just or any language
well jobs jobs to work now I don't per
bunch a console that logs in there and
just see what's going on in the dev
tools so let's have a look console dot
log use effect here you see just run the
once-great right here now let's run into
an infinite loop because we love
infinite loops so I'm going to stick
story ideas in there so this is going to
run and it's going to be like okay well
I'm going to set the story IDs with data
oops
I'm going to set the story IDs with Dare
and this is watching story IDs so it's
like okay well story IDs have just
changed I need to rerender this and when
it gets here again it's gonna re render
well it's going to set this
once mark up here and then this is gonna
be like oh well story ideas have changed
again I need to redo this function and
just keep going round and round and
round because once this is resolved we
kind of basically set the story IDs the
user effect is watching the story IDs
and it's gonna come back in here key
pre-rendering and we'll show it i'm
aircraft my tub doing this but they well
look at that
it's going crazy 25 just really
rendering and I think Crum should have
stopped it no it doesn't i think Firefox
does de so I need to set that out I'm
gonna my laptop messed up fire oh yeah
perfect for back to normal
yes and now infinite loops there but
yeah that's how use effect works here's
another way to what we're looking at
later so we'll be looking at clean up
and clean up basically is when you want
to just clean up anything some sort of
subscription or something like a layout
effects so if you're messing with a
layout like a and calling a scroller you
don't want to be re rendering all the
time and it causes implications to that
but I'll explain while there but now now
we've got the story IDs
I want to refactor this out and say okay
give me a container and I'm going to
call this concert a oops not a new
folder I want to call this container
what we're gonna call it well I just
let's just do it in plain English it's a
storage container let's just do storage
container I think I think that's as
simple as you can get without to be
honest so let's grab this start off here
stories we're going to need react I've
got to go up one more for that and we're
gonna need we've got basically need this
alright so if I just put this right back
to normal
come on you can do this
oops yeah that looks good to me
we'll just bring that in oops just bring
it in there that looks good rename this
in here two stories container storage
container stringify looks good and then
you know what I'm gonna rent a storage
container stories container and where
did we put it well we're putting it in
containers it's next to it let's go
stories container seen as though this is
a component you know what render that
component there we are perfect nice
refactor so now we have a our story
[Music]
storage container and we've got all the
IDs
what we need to do now is create well
essentially we want to be able to pass
an ID up to the hacker news API and
we're going to be doing in here so let's
do X dot Const and instead of get story
ideas let's go sell it get story and
this is an S synchronous function that
takes in a story ID and then we're gonna
say Const result pretty much the same as
before a wait Axios get and we're gonna
give it a template string I'm gonna say
story URL which is this here so we're
going to say okay give me this and then
just item front on the end which is good
and then we're going to set plus I try
not plus I'm living in the old world of
JavaScript here let's just say actually
we could do plus their story ID there's
other ways to do with template strings
but was that we do that for now instead
Jason and then of course we have to
resolve this so let's do dock then and
you can see all the the intellisense is
telling me you're not to over resolve
this will do the same as before
let's the structured data out of there
and once we got the data we're gonna say
give me the dare return the data that's
all we're doing and you know what we
need to return this result
because now this is a promise that gets
returned we're gonna have to you know
let's test it what we've got here it's
gotta get stories I see do we could
actually just do will say if stories IDs
and story IDs is dot lymph it's greater
than zero because firstly it's not going
to be there actually let me just show
the implications are passing an ID right
up there let's grab this one what do we
expect it to be I switch out that ID so
expect it to be I don't know what that
is but anyways let's posted this ID so
yeah we're passionately side D with you
know such like pass it down like that
and now let's resolve it and I would say
console dot log yeah that looks good to
me
boom there it is there's the story and
you see matches up with this perfect so
we know that works which is great so we
bit so I just built a service in here
that can call them the hub can use the
API and that's all it is that's all that
is for the API so pretty simple right
really nice we can get data from
elsewhere and we obviously have to build
on top of this so at some point in time
we're gonna have to build a story so
let's take a look now what else we can
start working on we've got our story IDs
and we've also got our stories well we
can get a story which is that which is
really good so let's go ahead and
quickly take a look so if we just hop
back have a look
we've got the story IDs so
let me see here
I guess what we want to do from this
point C we want start building out the
well the apps gone so the components
let's create a story is component and
here input react and then let's go ahead
and do export Const story
[Music]
so let's see we've got the returned if
we just dump something in here actually
let's pull in used to use effect C and
then we'll do the standard stuff use
effect we know how that works now what
we do want is we want get story and in
that get story we might get from
services and how can use API let's see
so story it returns and we're just I am
a story so look at this that historic
container
so in story container what we're going
to be doing is we're gonna be looping
over these stories so we've got five
hundred and so let's just loop over
these and we'll do let's just say story
IDs dark map and we'll set for each
story ID so when we map another it's
gonna give us a story ID again this
could be anything this could be lemon
piece waiver it may be but I just call
it story ideas that make sense and then
we'll say give me
why should we give me give me the story
component let's import that and that's a
story so it was a component and it's a
story component and that lives in
components and we're importing this as a
named in part because we exploit it as a
named experts we have to do as a named
input so let's have a look here so there
let's pass story ideas of prop so for
every story component that gets rendered
on the page we're gonna pass the story
ID and this is one of those have a look
I'm story I'm a story I'm a story cool
but what this story ID is gonna be if we
just serve this and go back and pass
this in here we can say story ID and
let's just have a look what that story
ideas there we are perfect so we get the
story ID and that means we can now use
that story ID to make a call over to the
hacker news API again to get the story
information back and if you come in from
two traditional backgrounds where you've
got parameters and arguments so you can
pass an argument into story you would
probably see something like this but
seeing as though this is not a function
well in some ways it's a functional
component which it actually is but we
cannot use the parameter as such we have
to destruct you that out like so by
giving curly brackets and the reason for
this is in react so let's have a look so
we get story ideas here story ideas come
through
let's see they were coming through I
guess the story ID is Jason dot
stringify
did I crush it because that's rendering
out 500 components objects are not hard
as real children object with key story
ID there we are so we've got the story
IDs but let's say for example sick we
just call this props and we've got the
structure anything out of there and I'll
just remove this and we'll do console
dot log not console dot log but I want a
bit I'll see on the pitch I'll just say
stringify
props let's take a look there we I see
here so basically all we're doing is
just destructuring how the story ID
which will give us this so let's put up
back to normal and you'll see that
pattern everywhere in reality is it
basically saves you from having to do
props dot story ID which is a quite
long-winded story ID so now what we want
to do is we want to make a call and
scene as though we've already built this
get story we're just going to pretty
much follow the same method would have
done here where are we doing get story
IDs and then place it into story IDs but
instead we're going to say you steer and
within you steer what we're gonna do
we're going to call this story let's do
that once more you stir story set story
and the initial story we're just going
to set it's an empty object so within
our use effect you can come down here
and we can say get a story from in here
which will be this and then we can pass
it the story ID which is basically just
this proper gets passed down
we'll resolve this asynchronous function
and said there and sometimes on this API
I've seen not a.com with the URLs so I'm
just gonna say okay once we've got the
data once it's been resolved and you
know you've got the deer in here I'm not
just going to return it I'm gonna say
and and to make sure that we have a deer
dot URL and if we do have a date URL
we'll go set story to dinner and that's
pretty much it and you do I have to
watch for a story idea changing so
niska's I'm going to disable that yes
lint rule because the the fact the
matter is here is this story ID either
even though it's it's kind of component
base where we only need it once we'll
need this story ID once and that's
pretty much it we don't expect it to
change maybe if there's comments on
there but in this case is not but if
this comments on there we could watch
for comments changing and then will
recall the API to get updated comments
for example but in this case we don't so
we're not going to watch for anything
I'm just going to say soon as this
component mounts do this which gets the
story and we pass it star ID then it
gues resolves the the function gives us
there and then we're going to do a check
for the URL and then if all is good at
that point set the story so now let's
have a look so it should have a story so
it's just jason dot stringify
story and what be there immediately
let's take a look it will be there
immediately but there you see them laden
in perfect we've got an empty one here
which we can resolve later by just
making sure that we filter out empty
ones and another one there
you see how the stories come in and
there's quite a lot of them there we go
perfect
so now we've jumped back in here we can
start just building up this component so
we can just say if there's a story so
this will get rid of that you know empty
object and well this bit will and story
dot URL then go ahead and just give it P
tag and just says story dot story dot
title and we want to execute this as
JavaScript we just want to get some P
tags so that's why I'm just wrapping in
these curly braces story dot title and
we'll put this actually in here F
because we want the URL so it says story
dot URL and then from here or now we
else do we have
we have story dot bye so we can set by
we see story dot time we can come and
fix that let post it and we just said I
got post it time I don't believe we have
much more so we can just take a look at
that right now
and let's see let's see what we've done
oh I always have to return something in
the render so even in this case I'm just
gonna return null which is fine looks
there bye yeah they're all there and
that's what I was looking for that's all
simple is to make the API calls and we
get this complaint in here so each child
in a list must have a unique key prop so
we can fix that by going into storage
container because that's what it's
coming from storage container grab this
story ID because we know that's never
going to change and this is how we act
checks for updates as well to see what
should be update and in what particular
position so if you look at
reconciliation within react there's a
good post on the react documentation
about how the reconciliation works on
why the key prop is very valuable so if
this is changing don't put it in the key
so if you're using something like math
dot random it's a it's a bad thing to
use because when it's looking for
changes it's like all the story ideas
change even
probably the component there hasn't but
it will be fetch all the stuff in there
and the positioning for example on a
list could be wrong but nevertheless had
only digress into that just have a look
as to how that works so we've got our
stories now there's none null ones which
is good we don't need to get story in
here for the story con Turner have a
look where we're at now we have any
hooks mother's one thing I do want to
career is something to handle what comes
back from the API so if we just take a
quick look as to what's gained so if I
just remove this quickly for one second
actually remove all that no nope
Jason dot stringify and what story
so since don't know so I'm just logging
now what's instead as wanna see what's
in there and you see how I got
descendants we have whoops this is quite
a lot y'all got descendants okay I just
use this as a example type we don't care
about the type we don't care about the
descendants the scar so we're gonna get
rid of that so when it comes back from
here we'd only do it at this particular
level will do it and get story but let's
take a look in get story and what we're
gonna do we want some self function that
selects the fields nicely so we'll
select fields and we'll just rub that
and it's going to say okay well it's not
defined okay I understand that so if
we're going to utils we could just call
this select field is now if in select
fields dot J assets just do X but Const
and then we'll call this select fields
and then we'll give it a function that
the structures are ID by URL time title
and then we'll say okay if this stuff's
you know if it comes in and there's
there's an occurrence like this
potentially could be emptier so for
example let me just finish this function
let's say return me an object with ID by
URL time title and there we go
so we've got select field so that should
just bring us back this stuff now I
shouldn't have like descendants Oscars
or anything like that but if we pass
something in here that just happens to
be like undefined
let's default it to an empty object so
that's file done select fields we need
to import it in here now
so just set imp select the fields from
utils select fields perfect let's go
back and we can actually test this by
just heading oh I wasn't good we can
just test this by here and coming in
here just in dot stringify
and let's see if we have the descendants
as far as I can tell there's no
descendants in there which is good so
I'll put it back to normal we should
have the stories going in I see yes we
do
perfect okay so we've got the story
content now we've got the Oh kind of the
structure ID of undefined or null
where's this happening
it's like fields so we have to make sure
that when we're actually passing into
that select fields that we're not
getting it anything that's potentially
going to be null so if we open up the
hack and user API well say okay once
you've got the data we're gonna set data
and which basically says ok if it's not
normal it's true for value go ahead and
pass it into there and then we will run
into that issue
that's the hacker news API part finished
we want to implement infinite scrolling
test but we're going to look at that a
bit later down the line but one thing I
want to show you right now is well one
thing I want to work on right now I
think this looks quite boring so I want
to give it a few styles and you know
just make it a bit nicer so let's go
ahead and add in styled components
because that's what we're going to be
working with and we're not going to go
too complex as I said at the start this
tutorial I said that but we're going to
be looking at how you can just manage
props and stuff change ability we've
been start components but yeah we'll see
we'll see if they are how how it goes I
do like you know sass so not fully
switched on start components just yet
but we'll see so we've got style
components now so it can actually let's
start doing the MC we've got a Styles
folder yes we do so let's call this
story Styles digest and we've been here
I just say import styled from styled
components and do expert Const
and the way style components work is it
gives you back like a component somewhat
of a wrapper boys more of a component so
if you've got I say we call this story
wrapper and what's that styles because
you always have to give it this Const
I'll which is the interface so what's
that style thought and we'll give it
like the semantic markup so we're gonna
set section and then template tags and
just do whatever you want in here so say
okay padding top which is ten margin but
I'm gonna need a margin bottom on the
starry wrapper all the top 1px solid and
we've got a ccccc I'm gonna say okay
first of type and we're going to
probably have issues with one we've got
a title
we got one a border on the top one
likewise lust of type
remove that or say margin bottom zero
padding bottom zero looks good to me so
less important just see how it looks
one thing I do story stories content I
think in here we need some sort of them
I don't know maybe some titles just of
what's going on right now I'm gonna call
it so we've got the map right now I'm
going to call it hacking use the API but
like I said in the next tutorial after
this one we're gonna be using graph QL
and grabbing a bunch of different news
api's and we can and not be really
interesting to see I can use graph QL is
the the middleman in and we can create
services around that so let's just give
this a fragment which allows us to
render siblings next to each other and
Doug you're confused by this is just
saying okay we can render two components
next to each other like and put it one
component two but you cannot pass any
props to this fragment if you want not
you want the reactive fragment one and
then you can pass like a key value but
let's just let's not digress we'll give
it a fragment I'll chuck this into some
JavaScript and then also what I want to
do here is I'll just give this hitch one
that says hacker news stories let's see
where we're at so hacking you stories
and then see we have the map what's this
wind unit unterminated jet jet and
contents
no see I've lot I've gone into bracket
hell oh no stop there we are this is
what so what's this saying here expected
unreachable card
what's unreachable oh the lint sir is
not serving me today there we are
so it's sucking new stories and there
they are loading imperfect so let's go
ahead and grab our Styles it's called
stock story rapper in this case so what
we want to do now is we want to go ahead
and import this or set input story
rapper from Styles story styles and down
here let's just basically rebuild a bit
of this so we know we're going to be
testing this letter on slicer story
rapper and we'll give it a dare test ID
of the story just to make sure it's
there
start your rapper and let's just see
where we've got we've got to with that
okay so we've got a bit of putt in you
see it's been injected you see it gives
it a class a class name which is nice
and gives it some weird class name but
it's quite cool how it does that so
let's go back into our story styles I
don't know if we want to do too much
more in here I know we've got actually
we do have two other things to do we've
got a title and we also have the meta so
like time and buy so let's do a textbook
Const and what's their story title we've
been that title we just want some fairly
generic but what's their style dot H 1
again we using this semantic tag inside
dot H 1 dot section you could in here do
you know div or whatever it may be and
now it's margin-bottom
5px just pull this up here
font size 18 PX line-height 1.8 give a
margin of 0 text-decoration:none give it
a color of ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii ii
ii ii ii see maybe is that the one
background color or aid DCE 3d
text-decoration:none and then we've got
the matter in here to saucer well god
pretty much it with the same routine
it's a story meta we've got a styled div
have a look
one font-style:italic so when you've got
stuff stuff like the by the offer who is
going to make that italic and since
we've give it will give a span or say
which is not the first child but before
that child
give me some content of oh let me just
go grab the bully's snippet from my
snippets cons here
snippets tall box yeah and you put that
on a keyboard shock so i use it all the
time margin bottom margin right margin
left you could actually just do for this
you could probably for sure on CSS you
could do 0 so that i target top and
bottom this would target left and right
and then we'll say story and go use bem
still on story bold or my bald i think
we should be good but we can test this i
normally just write out a bunch of CSS
and test it after all i say it's gonna
have a meta element which will be our
sponge and then we'll set
font-weight:bold
and this is probably the furthest we're
going to get in terms of complexity with
style components but we just say okay if
there's a color and we pass some props
so that will say props dot color so i
thought yes or you know give it a red
color and that's one of the aspects of
style components you can pass props in
so if i was to use
story element story meta element and
passing color I guess you could just
pass FFF but white that would give it
the white color if not it would just if
I didn't pass any give it red so I can
have a look so the star components there
I'll move the story just one table over
so we've got in here now we've got
storage title slice tech this and pretty
much what we're going to do we just got
start replacing what we've already got
so let's do story title and we'd no
longer need P tags in here get rid of
those that's good to me and we've got a
story wrapper so I just circuit we're
already imported from story style so
let's just got back and say give me the
story title to give me the story meta
give me the story element so now we've
got which barb it wasn't your target to
buy so let's go down here was a story
meta because we said we wanted to target
a span will say storage by give it the
span probably going to dare test ID on
these as well so they're a test idea
calls story by and then I says story
meta element because that's what we used
and again well again but as I mentioned
earlier we can pass in props or so give
this a color of black and that's good
enough for me and we'll just set by and
then was that story dot by that looks
nice that does look nice and you know
what just for the sake of brevity I
guess in this particular point so I got
a story meta it's copy this source s
story time story time also instead of
time will set postage so what will come
to fixing that later down the line as to
how we can get some nice dates to say
okay this got posted you know to two
hours ago or 20 minutes ago whatever it
may be
and then was story time so if there's a
time and said map time and I know
there's always gonna be a time but on
that first render of reacts cuz it'll
render and said the stories out there
just yet or there's no story in that
component it's gonna run through this
even though it's gonna check for the URL
so we should meet together so it should
just be able to call map time which will
allow us in the future to give it that
nice URL but if you don't make mitigate
it here with the story most likely
you're going to get some errors in here
because it's gonna be trying to access
prepares a certain opposition's in
objects that do exist or if you're
calling functions like here and there's
no a quality check before it's going to
call that function pass something and
maybe that function blows up down a line
so just just be aware of that
going going forward so I see it all got
here that looks good nice and clean
after sir and I don't know what people's
faults are in new lines for stuff like
this I sometimes do like display up I
don't know how much shushes play or buy
I mean that does look quite nice Bowl so
does that I think I'll keep it like that
for now so anyways let's go ahead and
take a look what's going on
do we have any nice stories Oh somewhat
somewhat it's not too bad it's not too
bad I'll take that I'll take that for
now so it looks like now because the
stories are going all across appears
we're gonna have to create something
that's going to allow us to lock in that
story container so let's take a look at
a story container I did think I added a
space there but let's take a look I
thought and I added one here clearly not
I see I I thought you could use a
template literal so I just sir let me
get rid of this one thing you could do
here I guess is I guess we could push
out that we could use a margin but let
me use this particular level to give it
a bit of space in
hmm let's see
I suspect is there I was looking at the
posted once so when you got back uh
Chile
put that back story doc time we're going
a time so we have a class name on there
do we you know I may even tag in story
lock time because if if not I could
probably get rid of that we don't need
that class name right now story dot bye
because we're using star components we
can actually target the semantic
elements instead so let's just get rid
of that too although I guess in here so
we got we've got two spans story by
story time let's take a look at the
first one so the by we're going to be
expecting we're gonna be expecting that
it comes in yeah so that looks good to
me we've got the italics let's take a
look here see I was quite slow and
jerking a bit because he's loading 500
stories in the UI struggling so we're
going to take a look at how it can fix
that having an infinite scroll it's not
good user experience right now so yeah
so we've got this one on italic so I
believe the buff on italic duh sir let's
have a look so if we went to story
Styles yes which is we're gonna set span
not the first type let's say span first
child so margin right 10px let's just
see if one get a bit of space in between
that I guess one thing we could do is
put like a bullet in between there are
just something to split up
so we're saying we're in story matter
which is here this says spun oops spun
first chart so we want to target this
one here so spun or we don't need that
was spam first child there we are we've
got some nice and some nice padding on
there so let's let's go ahead and take a
look now styles and what we want to do
in styles now is I kind of want to lock
this container so story stories
container styles maybe I can come up
with a better name for that down the
line so it's import styles and then
we're going to be importing create
global style from style components
reason want to do that because I want to
insert something into the body so we
need to use create global style so if I
do X book Const global style was head
create global style and I'm just gonna
the rabbit is sick post in my default
config for most websites which is just
this just to reset and the box size
inserting the margins in a color and
then I guess what we want at this point
for global styles I think that's pretty
much it but we can inject that component
now but in terms of locking the content
of SS stories can turn a wrapper style
dot min down here remove that and then
we'll say max with one four zero pad in
top and bottom 20 left and right 15
imagined Auto sort of go in the middle
and that's our stories container stars
done so we can import a lot now so let's
go up here in and what we're gonna do
here is because it's our container we
want to import what we just got there
was a story styles storage container
it's fine sorry content style so we want
global style and story content a wrapper
so grab that we'll just push them in now
light sir and we'll say from styles and
then storage container styles perfect
and what we can do here now we can just
dump in this as a component so global
styles and then also we want the wrapper
so we can just give it a dare test ideas
make sure the wrapper comes in so we'll
so do we get a storage container when
we're going to test this if so brilliant
let's have a look I will just see if
we've got a nice there we are it's in
the middle it's loading it's gonna you
know making those huge amounts of API
calls so I hope the huh can use the API
doesn't like shut me off at some point
or after this video there'd be a lot of
requests I'm hotter API so let's just
did we have the title the title looks
fine right now so that's good
yep a key news there we are
plus a new name brilliant so yeah we've
done well that sauce that's up pretty
much our styles at this point so they're
styled components covered as you can see
it's quite jerky and if you did you know
run this in react to the components
you've got a bunch of stuff going on in
here with different keys and if you you
know run the profiler you can see it's
gonna take a little bit of time see
stop profile links it's probably going
crazy at this point and you can see
we've got seven point seven milliseconds
that's most likely staff components
taking up that particular particular
performance hit their story Bucky 9.2
milliseconds 0.9 or 33.1 so you see all
these components being rendered here and
I only managed to get 308 have a lot
ranked chart so this context consumer
imagine that's a start component lost it
and doing its magic
so I'm not - salt sold on style
components at the minute if someone can
you know give me a good reason to use
them the only thing that I well one of
the things that I'm not too sure about
was calling them as components because I
imagine you could get a lot of
components just laying around that
styles unless you do what I've done here
where you just have a wrapper and
targets there the hitch once aligned
story you know I'm targeting the air tag
here for the link I'm targeting the
sponge it could get quite crazy so yeah
I mean if there's a CSS expert help
there are style components X but feel
free to jump in the comments and let me
know all you know and find me on Twitter
which is in the description myself kind
of assertion and I want to be sold on
stock components and anyways so we've
got all our Styles we've got a fairly
good-looking FBI at this point one IFPI
application that caused an API work two
different routes so we're calling
stories ID and then we're calling we're
requesting for a story by that
particular ID so if we just recap where
we're at we've got a container that
houses the story IDs and then when the
story IDs come in and have rendered to
the page we call the story component by
using the map and the maps going to go
over about five hundred times if that's
what comes through but we'll do may get
out some story ideas that actually would
not MIT to get out any story ideas so we
get five hundred stories being called
what we do do what we do do what we do
happen to go ahead and do is we when a
component mounts we you know set the
story in storage doesn't happens being
there we're just return null and wait
which I find is that you know more than
adequate but yeah if there's if you do
feel as a there's a better way to do
this but I mean how can use the API is
in great in the sense that you're
getting five hundred requests coming
back be nice to you know be able to put
pidgin pagination in there so I'll be
like give me the you know the first
twenty I'll give me this next one here
but we're going to look at building that
in ourselves too
helped at the thought performance of the
application so we will be looking at
stuff like infinite scroll very soon one
thing I wanted to do is create this
matter so we will was in we were in
story Jes and I sit down here we want to
map the time so instead of giving us
this like unique timestamp we wanted to
say like two minutes ago or five minutes
ago you know yesterday two hours ago
whatever it may be and you can find
these online these I've called a mapper
and but you know it's different names
for it essentially all is is I'm just
gonna say it's a function that passes in
the time stamp and then it will return
me different scenarios based on you know
different intervals that are going on so
if we set seconds and will serve
math.floor and they'll get to hooked up
on this set of stuff this is a function
of I had laying around for a long time
and used it many times but it's not
reacts this specific so sir and that
dere needs to be called with some
promise or so let interval muffed off
law and then there's a bunch bunch of
different you know divisions and
additions going on in here so instead of
boring you insert with this this muffs
that's going on I'm gonna paste that in
there from one of my snippets over my
keyboard which is basically go ahead and
figure out you know is it years ago is
it months ago days ago I was go it's not
specific to react so I don't really want
to be teaching this it's just a map
function that gives you some nice deaths
so if we just put that in here so
certain map time map time so it's gonna
run that function over that story time
which is good so set input and we'll set
up time from mappers time give us a nice
deer so let's have a look again they're
two minutes ago three minutes ago
whatever it may be but what what's quite
crazy here is it's hitting our API you
know all the time so it's hitting that
500 times so we have to slow that down
and but yeah let's take a look where we
are now
we
you need a spare such a despite here so
uh he says posted so was posted live
so looking starry okay post it is down
yeah there is so yeah let's just give it
an empty template strings you see if
that all fix it there we are that does
it nice and but yeah I guess so we've
got the story component so it's a nice
little learning project this you've got
one component that goes often calls an
API you've got a container that goes
often causing the API that is it it is a
component but don't get this mixed up
with say no this is a container it is
just a wrapper so that's my words this
is not react specific it's me just
saying this is a component container
that wraps a bunch of stories so I mean
let's have a look here what we got going
on with our styles we got services so
containers mappers selectors services
just all made-up words just like
component but these are more why I like
to work with so like you know you've got
your map has your selectors actually in
this case seen as a a util I guess a
util could be putting as a selector so
we'll move that and hopefully vs cards
smart enough to figure that out yeah is
look it's found it it's given me this
and it said it said select fields is now
a selector can you serve this for me
sure I'll serve that and it should still
work perfect that's brilliant
okay okay so now I think it's time that
we maybe started doing the infinite
scroll so let's have a look so as you
can see we've got a bunch of stories
here and it takes a little bit of time
to load because it's requested in 500
and now I'll be hitting the micro task
queue so if we go ahead now and say
we've got constants with dot new
components right now what we need to
create and I don't want you to get too
hooked up on this but we're going to
create a hook called
use in the note infinite scroll dollar
je s and with the infinite scroll we're
just going to do the standard stuff
input reacts then we're gonna go ahead
and say I sure don't need react for this
we just need a few methods from you so
you steer use effect that looks good and
come down here we need some constants
now so in our constants file let's go
ahead and just index KS and essentially
all we need in here is two constants
Xbox Max stories and we're going to
we're now we're going to get 500 so I
just put 500 in there and then story
increments is equal to Phi and if we go
back into the infinite scroll what we
want to do we want to import story
increments max stories from constants
and then I'm gonna come down here expert
Const
use infinite scroll this doesn't have to
be hooked but I'm in the mode of
creating hooks at the moment so I
thought I'd show you how to do these and
since this is a tutorial I may as well
take the opportunity to show you how to
use custom hooks so we're gonna say
loading set loading equal false we're
going to initialize a state with false
and then we're going to do another you
stir it so you stir or set count and
then set count and then you stir story
increments so we're going to set the
count starts at 30 so say if we did
something JavaScript like it's you know
if we use slice slice from 0 to 30 when
user Scrolls got from 30 to 60 and all
we could say it got to 0 or 60 because
we want to display all the stories we
don't wanna get rid of the other ones
the other ones stuff we could just keep
doing this until we'll hit 500 so what
we want to do now is we want to do
something great method
essentially so well ultimately what
we're going to do here is just set
handle scroll and then we're going to
say we need to get the window so if I
just log out window here should be able
to access the window directly and react
so look go into your console in dev
tools we have to import this actually so
if we go into it should be all get rid
of that don't need that don't need that
we don't go into storage container then
we do in we should say mmm use in the
net scroll from hooks use infinite
scroll and then if we let's see if we
just go ahead and look where the
structure up count because we're going
to return we go return count with not at
a moment so I just say test I'll call
that method it's never to find a cure
I'll call handle scroll that's when I
see what I want to show you what window
returns here here we are
access to the window so there's a bunch
of stuff on here that we can access but
I don't want to confuse you too much as
to you know what's what all this stuff
is we could leave out for another
tutorial but you've got the stuff like
local storage animations the Navigator
stuff a lot on key down all these Dom
best actions the origin the outer height
the outer width but more specifically
what we're looking for you have in a
height should be in here somewhere in a
height and then we'll say well that's
what we're looking for now and then
myself
document so even though we got in a high
what we want to logout should be able to
look for document element and then
within document element there should be
scroll top somewhere there we are
if used to reload up window this should
update but what we want to do want to do
a calculation say okay in a in a height
plus the scroll top it's not equal to
the offset so let's have a look for the
officer should be in here so look there
we are
offset height so it's want to make sure
it's not bigger than that and right now
you can see it's pretty crazy if it's
said if it is bigger than that that
we're going to set attribute say if it's
loading or if it's not loading and then
also we don't want to be hitting a
refresh with react all the time so
something we can do is put a concept on
this function called the debounce to
make sure if I scroll I cut this keep
scrolling scrolling scrolling when I do
hit a scroll it locks my scroll officer
500 milliseconds or thousand
milliseconds wherever it may be just to
make the experience a bit better so
let's take a look now just go back in
here we can delete that delete that I
was doing that for a second
what we're going to do in here we're
going to you know do that conditional
check in here to make sure that we can
calculate the hike regular and then we
can do certain conditions best around
the height but please do not get too
hung up on this this is base I'll just
check in if you've scrolled and then
what we're going to do we're going to do
some rewrites type stuff right okay as I
mentioned don't get hung up on this but
I should say okay if window dot inner
height plus document dot document
element dot scroll top is not equal
- the document.documentelement got off
set height or if it's loading if that
condition happens to be true for example
well depending on our condition comes
back ours we can deserve it some false
and then else set load in true and now
set up cool that's good
well pulley News effect and what will
God do we use effects we're going to
have two of these in here to listeners
so if it's not logged in just return out
of here because we don't want to be
going ahead and doing all the set load
in unlocking the count will say if count
+ story increments is greater than or
equal to max stories then set count max
stories and what that's saying is
basically if we have a count of 480 plus
the story increment which is fir that
equals 510 and we don't want to get let
the users keep scrolling because we've
already exceeded the max stories right
so we're just going to set the count to
500 and you know quit the scroll in
there else if the if the are below 500
stories like to set count so we could
start off with 30 they scroll once on
the page we're going to add star
increment which is 30 so you'd have
initial count plus another then it it 68
and if the user Scrolls again because
the counts changed we'd hit night now
and we do that so it gets 500 stories
and whilst that's all going on just a
set loading false so that we can
continue on and we're going to keep a
watch with our use affect our unloading
and we're going to do one more user
facts and I'm doing two separate use
effects because I don't want to be
watching actually you know what I don't
care about count in there so let me get
rid of disable that and I should just
add the exhaustive dependences I want
another use effect because I don't want
to do anything in here I just want
to run just the once so we're gonna do
the component in mount this is rewashing
loading all the time for a change value
this one is just going to do it once
some will say window dot add
eventlistener
and I want it to listen for the scroll
and then handle the scroll let's just do
this and one important aspect here is we
have to sort of unsubscribe from this
event listener and the way to do this to
do a cleanup in our use effect in
reactors return a function does window
remove event listener and also remove
the scroll and then remove that method
too and that's saying okay we're gonna
add the event listener and then once
this use effects done go ahead and just
remove this listener because we got on
these to be hanging around and creating
multiple listeners or whatever it may be
we just want to do a quick cleanup in
here and after all of this who's got
their return count so we should be able
to use this now it should be in a
workable stare but there's still some
stuff that has to be done to it so I
should be able to grab this and say
Const
counts equals use infinite scroll and
what we want to do down here even though
we've done the map what we want to do
now is we want to set dot slice start as
zero and then go with the count so for
example if the count so the user comes
on the page it's going to be zero and 30
user Scrolls it's going to be zero 60
user Scrolls again 0 98 user Scrolls
again 128 and so on and that's what's
going to happen but then you probably
send to me now but it's gonna re render
a bunch of these components are already
on the page is gonna re render them for
no particular reason like that's bad
right yeah we don't want to be rerender
in these stories all the time so there's
a perfect solution in react for this and
what we're gonna do we're gonna pull
that in from up here and it's called use
meme' I don't want to implement this
right away
I chose called memmer what my talk
but I don't wanna use this right away
because I want to show you why this is
very important so I save all this let's
have a look see if we've got a working
page they see the scroll bars better and
it seems to be broken so a lot what's
going on
so it doesn't seem to be scroll it maybe
there's something wrong in my user use
infinite scroll hook so what we got here
we got the loading let's debug this
together
she's gonna be doing a lot of debugging
go said count that's right we're gonna
handle the story so go say window plus
document element is not equal to the
offset height or Lord in return false I
was good to me and when I set loading
and what we're missing here we've got
another use effect that's saying if it's
not loading return if count plus story
increment is greater then set count set
town plus story increment max story set
loading false we're watching for loading
we have a use effects that adds an event
listener off scroll I'm gonna say use
this method for a handle scroll so when
so when we're listening and this happens
we're going to call that function and
we're going to return window dot event
listener scroll handle scroll so I think
I've spotted the bug but I just want to
go ahead and deep keep debugging this a
bit larger so we can get in yeah it's
never smooth sailing right we do want to
keep track of what's going on
see accounts for counts not six dear
and that's all it does it only goes to
60 very strange
does it go any further it only does one
scroll and I'm guessing so I pulled in
news so we don't have to watch the count
because what what's going to happen is
it should refresh each time so even
though we've got those stories on scroll
it's gonna fire back as if the counts
changed
so this cam will just update here use
effect okay so let's take a quick look
once more in here the you use infinite
scroll return seems fine for picking up
the event listener or watching the Lord
in I I'm gonna take a guess that this is
not working
simply because here it's something to do
with our debounce
or it's something to do with Scott the
story con Turner so you see it knows
counts updated so like counting here so
for example where it says count here so
if it's not loading go ahead if count
plus story increment is greater than or
not said story set false loading should
be up here so yeah it does look okay I
don't know if anyone spite this just yet
I think I know what it is hmm so I think
I know this issue is it comes down to
and this is what I actually like to
leave with you guys if you want to do
some work on this after if you've doomed
in the offset seems to be wrong by zoom
amount
I can hit the column ignore this message
at the minute we'll use a clean up
properly you see all accounts updating
for 60 90 120 150 and we should be able
to gets 500 aren't stoppers count should
hit 500 we see I can just keep scrolling
and then it kind of stops and it
requests whilst it's requesting 420 and
it's a bit jerk it's not the best
experience that's why we're going to
implement a debounce 500 and and that's
it what let me scroll any more perfect
so yeah let's have a look now are
implementing we don't need count in
there anymore don't need it there so
we're not gonna be watching counting
count should just up there here so when
this story container goes ahead and does
its work and gets the 500 look through
here and it'll say ok well infinite
scroll has changed this in here has
changed so if we're watching counts when
actually watching count in here but if
Lordan is being changed that means count
the counts changed so flooding does
change which is in this year's effect
here then what we'll go do go change the
count and we can update the count here
so let's take a look so what we can do
actually you know what I was going to
put a count let me let me put it back in
here a second I'm gonna leave it there
soak in debug you can actually put it in
yes what we need now okay that's good
what we need now is a D bouncer open up
your Explorer and it should be utilities
folder in here so let's have a look
we're gonna drop in here something
called debounce j/s and this is another
thing i don't want you to get hung up on
but let's create a function called
debounce it's going to take a function
go take a where it's going to take in
the media and then it's gonna take an
arse
and it may be a bit confusing I was just
thinking about this that why is this
updating YYZ stories content updating
and getting a new count each time well
I'll show you in the profiler in the dev
tools as to why this gets update so you
can see it visually because there's
nothing in here if I got rid account to
say well you need to run this use effect
apart from this infinite scroll
obviously but this use effect here it's
like well nothing's in here so why
should I update this component well I'll
show you shortly
it's better to visually see as posting
me explain it let's just do let timeout
will return a clean up function says
Const context this cons call now
immediate and there's no timeout console
later
timeout equals null I know I've
mentioned it plenty of times but I'm you
know I'm trying to teach as much react
as possible here so I don't really when
you get hung up on just an infinite
scroll if you are interested feel free
to drop some comments and we can talk
more about this more you can find me on
Twitter at Cal are doing I should set a
time outs I said later where and then if
call now function dot apply context tags
and that should be okay said timeout
that should be alright so to close up
and the way to apply that function is
what we want to do we want to apply it
in I using from the scroll where I've
asked on so we want to play want apply
it here so when handle scroll gets cold
we want to wrap it in a debounce so
we're going to say and it took parlor
import of d bounds from utils debounce
and we want to wrap the entire function
so if that this bit here actually this
bit this bit
all I'm is yeah a suspect so we want to
wrap this under scroll in deboned
and then we're going to do the deep
bouncy what's going on in here and then
you know forget yet the you know the
green light go ahead do the handle
scroll if not you know where hundred
milliseconds puts 500 and yeah basically
that's it for using infinite scroll and
it should just work now we've got the
infinite scroll it should give us a nice
debounce solve look there is it slot to
the scroller 500 milliseconds and feel
free to put that to whatever you like
whatever you feels the better user
experience so we have select fields we
have a bunch of stuff going on here I
don't know if it's at this point because
we have a functional up at this point
maybe it's uh do we have fixtures in
here no order maybe it's worth let me
create a folder close all these folders
down I'm just gonna create a fixtures
folder and the reason we're in the
fixtures folders because we're gonna
start preparing for tests or testing so
if we just go ahead and in our fixtures
well we can create an index yes index J
yes and what this does let's just
correct singular story so do expert
Const singular stories because we don't
want to be hitting the hacking user API
all the time especially when we're
running tests right so it's just the IDS
one time let me grab a UNIX timestamp
yeah we don't know be hitting this all
the time so the reason for that is we're
just gonna run the test against this
tarnish google responds it's one of the
articles I saw URL something something
calm new happy news
yeah we ought to be running the test
against the live site so it's just
export cons story IDs and you could go
ahead and check out the you know the
infinite scroll but uh I don't feel it's
necessary if we can manually test it and
it's just an empty story it would be all
this that was just so undefined so say
ID
time title URL grab these bum bum bum
looks good so we've got a fixture that
we're gonna import into our tests so do
we have a testing for that we do not
actually create new folder underscore
underscore tests firstly what we're
gonna do hmm
actually you know what there's there's
quite a few things to test here so what
I actually want to test we're gonna test
the application like kind of end to end
ish the hacker news API so our hockey
news service which is this we're going
to test a story container stories
container and then we've got tester
component which is stories itself so
let's take a look at that and we'll do a
few tests just to get some confidence in
our application it is obviously working
but these are few things that we can
test and you know just get confidence
whether it be this is going through a
shared core burst or it's going through
a pipeline we want it to be passing
tests so yeah let's take a look at that
and we'll jump in we're going to write
probably three or four tests we're going
to be using react testing library and
there's also some nice stuff you can do
here right so I've left you a project
I'm gonna leave your project after the
test is done I can go ahead and pull in
different API you can test it
differently you can remove the infinite
scroll you can modify the infinite
scroll and then once all this once this
video is released a week or two from now
you'll see the second video which will
be the graph QL implementation hooked up
to this and this will go from hacker
news application to a news reader the
news reader will read multiple api's and
then we'll modify an adapter and air
that can be returned to our front end so
what we're gonna do here I'm gonna have
to just modify the screen a little
hopefully everybody can see this I'm
just gonna throw my terminal in here and
I'm going to close that just so you guys
and girls can see what's going on
close that close that and what we're
gonna do is I'm trying to think which
test might be easy to brick in first so
we've got the story the stone at storage
container you know I jump right in
headfirst likes go ahead do tests up
spec is and what we're doing here in pot
reacts oops
input react and we need to import act
and act now react Dom test utils I'd
sure what I will explain act right now I
mean let me do in a second
it's basilar air synchronous rendering
so instead of well yeah okay let me
explain in a second you'll see you'll
see it back we need to import all this
stuff that way using because we do want
to mock this out and when I'm saying
mocking it's like giving it some sort of
thick response because we don't even
need to test this particular big that
well all we just want some empty
components because we're not focusing on
testing in testing them all we simply
like if it's actually us we don't to be
hitting an API right so there we are
looks good and we need to bring in the
infinite scroll use infinite scroll from
hooks use infinite scroll and the story
incremental we can bring that into I
guess increment I think constant wasn't
it was good okay we're gonna say this is
react testing library right here but I
said before each I can I make that bit
just a tad smaller
I seem to care for now I'll just pull it
over there for now I'll keep running
these tests we'll go step before each
this is before each test do a clean up
and by saying that it's cleaning up the
Dom which for me Oh actually you know
what one crucial thing I missed I forgot
to import the testing library clean up
generally I'll do in render and clean up
up all those in and maybe now sometimes
I might pull in what else do I normally
pulling maybe fire click event fire
event I think is do we have this
actually oh I think we have it
so what's let me have a look package ah
we don't have it ok we need to install
this so if you go ahead and Deb
dependences dev D you know I'm scrubbed
up dev dependencies when I say test in
Highbury reacts now say give me nine
five one three
I was just saying here call unexpected :
expected Wow really it's close that down
what's this doing here
spinner anyways let's go to package
Jessen I like it did with mine there
it's still going but let's just continue
on right in this up dot spec file
probably easy just to generally fire in
do a yarn ad react testing library so
let's go ahead and say describe and
we'll create a describe function that's
gonna give us what's gonna set up and to
be honest you don't even have to do a
describe because not much is going on
sir I'm not going to do a describe I'm
just going to set it one thing before we
do the it let's just do a yarn installs
we need the testing libraries you can
see we've got the the red squiggly lines
telling us basically it's unable to
resolve so once that's installed we
should get the testing library library
which would be nice and now I was just
thinking briefly then instead of using
it I generally use it as a function to
test off when it's inside the describe
block if it's outside the describe block
we can just do tests which makes a bit
more sense I'll say it renders the
application it has to be asynchronous
because we're doing asynchronous calls
and we're going to get the user infinite
scroll to find never used of care that's
fine
using finished scroll dot mock
implementation and then what we're going
to do set count let's go say return the
implementation of you use infinite
scroll return me count with 30 and
that's all I care about at this point
and that's all I ever won from used
infinite scroll so I don't
the actual implementation I just want
you to return me an object like this
count is equal to further and then we're
gonna have to mock the get story so
we're going to do mock implementation
again I'm gonna set promise dot resolve
because on that get story remember
because it says synchronous is always
going to return us a promise so I have
to resolve something and that's why we
had the fixture file fixture in here and
I'm just gonna say for this get star it
return merely singular object with this
stuff in here so I'm going to say
resolve me this I don't want to hit the
fbi's want you to return me this and
that's the power of a mock so get story
IDs mock implementation and once they're
promised don't resolve story IDs
likewise for the story IDs I don't care
about the implementation of get story
ideas you know hitting a kiosk I'm just
gonna say okay give me this function and
just return me a result that I'm
thinking essentially and that result I'm
faking it with is story IDs which is
this array here with one so I'm going to
say if you get one go ahead and get a
single a story
and this is where the real business
comes in so set of wit act I think and
then we'll set our own function and this
my friends is grid basically what's
happened recently is you didn't used to
be able to believe use an asynchronous
act so you couldn't do some work
say for example God get me these stories
because it's asynchronous and render
these I essentially one because when
this test runs it's just gonna run
immediately right and it's not going to
have say the story on the page so I want
it to await this so if we didn't aware
this and you get a bunch of errors
saying knows asynchronous tasks going on
and your renders all messed up so we're
going to use a way up and we'll take
that off that show in a second but I
want to show you this get by text query
by test ID
and I said render me the application
I see the no wait I'm gonna say wait for
the element and wait for element in
react testing libraries in asynchronous
utility that basically allows me to pass
it one element or an array of elements
to say once the asynchronous tasks have
happened do this so it's gonna say a wit
this dispar here so just wait on a
response from the asynchronous task once
it's resolved God do this stuff I'm
going to expect get by text hacker news
stories and you know what I want that to
be true free I want it to exist and
we'll do a comic because we're passing
an array here and I'll just manipulate
these query by test ID we want to make
sure our story buys there cuz that story
by is through the stories by and we want
to check in the text content so we can
check the text content here and since
there's going to be a bunch of story
buys we can't use get by text right well
really what we can't do is say you know
by this person up by this person get by
text only allows us to get one
particular element that's on the page if
there's multiple elements with a sim if
with a stamp text it just what works so
what we're doing here is we're query by
the test ID for story by and story by is
like a span tag so we're going to go
into that text content I believe it's a
spun side comment but we made it I just
want to say it by you know what I can't
remember what what we made it by in a
fix - I think it was by me actually yeah
by me that I don't need that looks good
how can you stories yep that's the title
and what we also want to do when I make
sure this is in here so I want to make
sure the titles in here and this will
all start making sensing see these
squiggly lines here saying look it's not
imported from react testing library
so yeah that all makes sense so let's go
ahead and just say yarn test let's see
what happens and I'll pull up the Cobra
g4 come on this ocular mock
implementation is not functional yet
so saying here we're saying News effect
from the hooks or what forgot to do
actually we have to create our initial
Mach so go say just ups jest up Mach - -
hooks use infinite scroll now give us an
initial Mach so it can start modifying
that Mach specifically likewise with our
services so I can use FBI you know as
soon as it loads in get me the story
Jess dot function and by returning a jet
stop function it allows us just to you
know make assertions on that function
did it get cold
did it get cold with this data all this
sort of good stuff so get story IDs so
that should now work I'll take a look we
could rerun that test automatically but
it kind of nukes my system perfect so
we've got count in here
well weapons I'm hoping we can
demonstrate I don't know if it's
possible to demonstrate assessing act we
may actually not need it with the way
from and oh yeah we'd actually need it
but that's how you do use async axis
come out and I think react 16.9 we don't
need it there but we may need it down
the line so we'll keep it in a tool bag
for now well let me just get rid of
these and serve that let's see what
happens here we are unexpected talk and
that's basically syntax error so rerun
that ennoble find an element with this
stuff great and why is that well the
page the test run but there's no content
so we have to aware that there so I can
do that by just saying putting this back
to a where Pharrell
and we also have an asynchronous test
here which is great so if we run that
test once more said that it's gonna
probably failed I think you caught it in
time to serve yo I did that's great we
can check out count because counts
basically a story Khan Turner don't need
that there Eva let's check a look that
looks good to me so basically that's how
we mock out while not mock out that's
how we test the spec so I'll pull up the
coverage now and then we can have a look
where stuff maybe we haven't here asked
if we do need to hit all right yes
sometimes when I run the test it don't
give me coverage and you can't set this
up in practice Jessen but I wanted to
give me coverage for everything not just
specific file sir even I sent it one one
test I was still want coverage and it
not to get cached so I saw the spec jess
running coverage perfect
we've got coverage if I got back here
open up have a look coverage where is it
see ah okay going to your package GSM
and what we want to do we have to have a
look for coverage reporters coverage
fresh old is a refresher oh there's
nothing in here okay okay we can do jest
and we've done this before in some in
like the to do is tutorial so collects
Archer I'm not gonna collect coverage
for a many I'm not gonna I'm just going
to get it from everything but so a
coverage threshold and this is a good
standard to get a good mindset to get
often always have a good fresh also
branches 95 functions
lines statements that looks good
coverage Rashard sis wins you know or
six to a look
unexpected talking about Oh
one two all right that seems fine we'll
see in a second so we've got coverage if
I spell that right threshold we have a
global of the global coverage and the
reason we're not getting any coverage
report is go where needs coverage
reporters give it an array of hitched
email and text and what that's gonna do
should give me oh yeah I didn't like
that coverage threshold and pretty sure
click coverage for arm coverage
threshold yeah I can't spell thresholds
so that's should work now should give me
a coverage report let's have a look
there we are index dot HTML perfect I've
got a lot going on here so we might have
to clear some stuff out that we don't
exactly want to be test in so we've
actually tested our story by just doing
an up file but I think what's best is if
we test it individually as a unit test
even though we did kinda test it and you
know you do get this fall over between
app and sorry container cuz kind of
doing the same thing but do as much
coverage as possible test everything you
possibly can if it's some necessary to
test you know you don't you don't have
to do it but let's have a look let's go
ahead next in Korea because this one's
really quite similar to stop it up so we
could just use this as a base I imagine
Clause that down
so it's pulling this is ABARES I don't
think we could is the exact same test I
don't even know if I have to test this
honestly yeah so we're going to be
hitting the story container it's gonna
be doing exactly the same stuff like if
you just require a story container here
whip up I mean I can leave it in here if
you wish containers containers
sorry container Kea come on
story concern a storage container and
you know what you'll probably get that
will most likely run completely fine and
you know you can modify stuff in a
storage container they look perfect but
I mean maybe you could just mock that in
the app and then you know just say okay
renders it just renders that's all you
wanted to do was opposed to doing all
this but anyways I'll leave that in
there let me see I'm gonna put this on
github so any modifications on the test
let me know I'd like to see that story
Doc's Specter jess is next clear that
out this one's gonna be you know it's
gonna be fairly similar maybe you want
to put some stuff in you test whether
the API fails but I'm not gonna go crazy
with the testing I'm not I am kind of a
purist but in the same hand and the
other hand I'm not I'd like someone
who's really good with tests I've come
and bought these up if possible but when
I start testing I'm like okay I've
already tested this stuff I've got
similar components being used throughout
so I may as well you know just copy this
to be you know I may as well copy are no
story IDs isn't being rendered in here
the infinite Scrolls not going to get
rendered we don't need the constant
infinite scroll I can go we're not doing
the story IDs because we're just
blocking at the get story renders even
his application renders let's change
that historic component with content so
what did we obvious story so that can go
said renders the story content with a
story so yeah I see here so we're gonna
say okay we're gonna mock out this
implementation with a single story
we are gonna render a story and we're
gonna give a story idea of one
components story story IDs don't need
that get story ideas do not need that
infinite scroll do not need so yeah get
story do we need a cleanup yeah we need
a cleanup but seeing as though there's
gonna be multiple mocks in here one nice
trick you can do put this down here it
will call that function like that and
then we'll set Jess reset all mocks and
that will reset on each test so this
sort of stuff are its mock
implementation here will fall into the
next test so we get clean test so we're
gonna clean the Dom and we also going to
clean all the mocks and I think even
though this is asynchronous yes it is
when I mock the implementation of a
single story we're gonna render out a
story plus it's a story idea of one cuz
that's in our fixture then we're gonna
whiff element and we're gonna say how
can use let's just actually like to say
also I know that we have a test ID in
there of I think it was story or story
always check component so should be do a
test ID in here yeah dare test ID story
which is there so if I basically just
want to call query by he knew to get by
test idea query by test ID hmm let me
just say I'd sure we could do query by
test ID you know I'll explain the
difference in a second let's say query
by test ID story I see what happens
get by test.txt
then we'll say hacking you stories isn't
gonna be there cuz that's not in the
container tarnish will be there text
content alright let's have a look where
we're up with a sir
yeah I'm test let's test everything I
can run individual tests as well I'll
show you how to do that in a second
works fine
perfect component story that's done
given that's covered in a number to test
but to run individual test you see yarn
tests give it the relative puffs and
just run that you can also run
individual coverage on that too so if I
quit out of there and say yarn test
coverage oh give me the individual
coverage for that as opposed to running
all the test coverage yes oh that was
good to me so let's take a look here so
we've got get by text query by test ID
[Music]
so let's expect query by test ID story
to be true they see oh it's all check in
perfect so if you switch that out now to
think it was get by get by test ID see
both work the same one of them I believe
so yeah so what we're looking at here
okay we want to see well the difference
between get by test ID and query by test
ID is and essentially what happens is so
you could use get by test ID if that
happens to be false so you could just
actually call this like that and if it
happens to be false it throw an error if
this here query by test ID happens to be
you know false you'll just return null
I'm not too sure which one I like most
I would like to get an error but you
could just do to true fit but in this
case I'll leave them in so you just see
how the work so let's have a look so get
by test ID let's just rerun that and
it's not gonna be there hopefully we'll
get a nice error stick in his time there
we are
give me an error unable to find but if I
run query by test ID on that it should
also fail because I've got to be true
fair but you see I doesn't give me the
debug in as well but if used to do this
so for example just called it here keep
an eye on this come on there I couldn't
find it so what happens if I do a query
by test idea should hopefully get an old
buck Oh doesn't really doesn't return
anything which is quite bad so in this
case I'd probably stick with get by test
ID honestly I think it's a bit safer so
we don't actually need that get rid of
that perfect that looks good to me let's
check out the check out the coverage no
yeah what was that on that was on story
spec yeah it's already covered from the
kind of an in aggression between the
upper and the story concern oh so a nice
one that we're going to be doing now is
the hitch ain't API digest hacking use
FBI our solid is you can stop running
those tests now and there's there's no
real need so this one we're going to
import we're gonna mock at cos we don't
actually use the rail implementation
we're gonna say from Axios and you don't
need the named import actually us is a
default so let's just set import get me
the story IDs get story new stories URL
story URL and this test is
is really nice actually I like this one
and it's not this one specifically but I
like testing it the ice because you can
see I did it get cold with this dad did
it not so I simple singular story we
need our fixtures empty single story
from fixtures yeah docks right how many
tests we got going in here now so what
did I do with this one I did test it on
just a one so yeah we don't really need
a describe here I mean actually you know
what we could do over describe here
because we're testing this on this so
firstly let's let's do a nested one how
can use the API forage and you can put
you before each by the way in the
describe just dot reset all mocks we
need some clean up and then we'll do
clean up did we not bring in we are
testing library actually do we need to
clean up we don't really need to clean
up because we're not doing anything to
the Dom here we're just basically tested
in the API described I say get story get
story functional I don't like testing
functionality but in this case you know
I'm breaking my own rule for now let's
just do one describe so what does it do
well it requests and gets a story from
the hacker hacker news API and then we
can do axial yet because that's a
function on Axios and we're going to set
mark that implementation because I know
that's what we've been using because we
did implement that right we use to get
back we're back over in service will use
this get and I just want to mock that
out so do promise dot resolve and I'm
going to say I want it to match exactly
how it runs through my day so I was
there and
spread a singular story in there there
we go that looks good to me
and then what we could do we could do
Khan's entity equals a where get story
plus it one and because this we're using
Ana where we need an asynchronous
function and what we can do now because
this is mocked and it's naturally gonna
call a can use API it's just gonna give
me this and that spread story what's
happening here with these three dots we
got a single a story I'm creating a new
objects which you probably just cook
this well you can just do sugar just do
that actually let's test it we'll find
out promised unresolved error which is a
single story we can test it and I see
happens so I said we want to expect
Axios what happened expect
Axios get to have been called x one and
we're gonna say remove that have been
called with and this is where the magic
comes in story URL plus one being this
here gets daria and then what we're
gonna do go said yes and because that's
what is actually going to be sending to
the hockey news API and saying give me
this story this number story of an idea
of one as i said it expects entity dot
so equal and we should build up a single
story in there let's test this
hypothesis and just see so I'll get that
yarn test I see what happens
maybe it doesn't like a singular story
going in it should not should do I see
requests so don't like the mock
implementation and I can already hear
everyone screamin amazed like you told
me to do this early you have to mock the
actual
insertion them the the module let's go
ahead and do that so we can actually you
know used use our mocks and we get the
mock implementation so soon perfect it
passed but reason we mock this is so we
can do stuff like mock implementation on
that so we know that axis isn't in there
we said what the implementation because
of God construct constructor ingest that
sets up all these nice functions for us
so like for example if used to run ax e
us we run this test she get a bunch of
nice stuff out here you see so we get
bunch of mock implementations here so we
do get the actual Axios will get the
access function and get mock
implementation clear all this good stuff
all because we did this but then you
also gets to fly here headers in scepter
response so you can get the original
functionality if you wish to get the
original functionality but in this case
we only care about the gap so we can
remove this Axios
maybe I can show you it also in the mock
implementation of the staris if I do get
story
figure I'll return just a function value
actually oops
grab that I see there we are so get the
get start because I've mocked it out
here and I've just said give me the jest
up function but you see the difference
in here is that's just gonna give me the
default mocks from everything whereas
the get story if I mock out that
particular function it's gonna give me
all this function outta here and then
you can run stuff light you know mock
implementation like that which is what
we'll use in there go ahead and do that
so yeah hopefully that makes sense I'm
always open to answering more questions
I know these can watching these videos
it can get quite tedious and some stuff
you may understand some stuff you may
not understand but I said essentially
that's that's programming you're going
to understand some stuffing you're not
gonna understand some other stuff and it
may click one day may not click another
day so always come back write notes ask
people it's the best way just
communicate people so what can do here
we'll say it does not retrieve a story
from the hacker news API but handles
gracefully let's put this over here
does not retrieve a story from The
Odyssey API handles gracefully I'm gonna
be rewriting a lot of this stuff when we
do hit the graph QL bit again we can
just go in here copy this and I don't I
don't want it to where we are I think
it's best I don't really care about a
singular story here I want an empty
singular story and we can mark an empty
single a story and we're gonna say we
want it to equal when it returns a
singular story so let's have a look
perfect just go back into story doc spec
and remove that console dot log there
she's getting all this stuff here
again this is all gonna be on this all
gonna be on github feel free to
contribute to the project graph QL is
come in so it's gonna be a newsreader
not specifically hacker news we will be
using hacking use FBI we're going to be
pulling other stuff as well using graph
QL get story functional air doesn't
retrieve so we've done the get story so
now all we could really got to do so
where are these braces describe
get story IDs us you know that's always
all we got left to do and we can pretty
much just go ahead copy this because
we've got similar implementation so it
makes our test nice and easy requests
and gets has changes the story IDs from
the Hockey News API we will mock out the
implementation of the get once more and
the reason we're not mocking this out
top is because we want to change it on
each test right and with clearing it on
each test as well by doing just reset
all mocks so here we're just going to
say give me story IDs which is in our
fixture if you forgot it's there in the
rear with one axis get mock
implementation promise not resolve
return me in an object with a key of
theater as a proper heir and that
property is in a rare with one inside
so we'll say get story ideas we don't
have to pass anything to get story ideas
and we can basically say how many times
it's been called once and we are only
only thing we really care about here is
does it hit the news stories URL because
that's what we plan on hitting it with
which is this a tilde pop this URL which
is that new stories and it should go get
me the new stories and then we'll say we
wanted to equal C story IDs have a look
what goes on here certain stuff of what
worried about mean our test perfect even
that's hitting the the wrong test
yes sir stuff of what worried about
within the tests
I'll try stay away from implementation
but doing these sort of tests gives you
confidence in your API so I quite like
doing them maybe it's just something I
like doing guess story functional ear
let's put that to get story IDs you can
see the names come inside here from the
describe and the test so how can use API
gets Dario requests and gets a story
there we are perfect so I'm just going
to go ahead now I'll check the coverage
report see where we're actually up be
useful if I actually run the coverage
sort of a look oh yeah the links were in
the description by the way for this
particular project and other projects
I've done all in the description i'm on
twitter at cal hadwin my github is in
also in the description at Carl had win
we don't care about hooks in this case
and we don't also care about utils I'm
not testing the debounce serviceworker
we don't care about that so okay in this
case we got very close to the end now
stuff I don't care about I mean this is
very subjective but certain stuff that I
can manually test I'm not gonna test on
the sly if I can just manually test it
get coverage from give it in a rare even
though the debounce don't what the
infinite scroll kind of works but when
you put it on a different screen zoom it
doesn't work too well so I could fix
that now or you
one of you want to fix it that would be
really nice not only would it serve me
the time but it would make this tutorial
shorter and also if someone could write
an implementation so this is why one
line competition but a few notes around
why it was like that you know that would
be nice but like I said people and other
people learning this I don't want you to
get hooked hooked up on a debounce I
don't when you get hooked upon all the
urban answers and the nuances that me
America I just want you to learn react
I'm not forcing you to learn react I'm
just saying these some of the good stuff
the functionality is for hooks this is
hooks this is components this is
containers all this stuff that kind of
brings it together as a react developer
so it's all good stuff to look out for
all these are like fundamentals and your
users get it there so anyways I'm gonna
rerun the test I'll show you I'm running
by the way for this Yan Tesco Bridge
watch all and hopefully a hundred
percent coverage wants to get rid of all
this all this nonsense here what we
don't my test I'm not testing a service
worker even though you can turn the
service worker on oh it's not met all
selectors is missing and by the way if
you do want a service worker I'm gonna
run this through lighthouse very shortly
Oh perfect hundred percent selectors
sugar in a second source selectors
select us like to select us that looks
fine to me let me rerun that one smart
come on
perfect you'll see this one here is
giving you a standing branches because
we never hit red but I wanted to show
you our style components working giving
you an opportunity to look at how props
work there too so you'll feel free to
change that if you wish so yeah let's
run this for a lighthouse right now I
think we I think we're done we've got a
working application we've got working
pretty quickly but then we just wanted
to make sure we could you know oh one
thing we didn't do we didn't implement
memo so this is this is a really good
thing so can I just get rid of the
terminal right now let me see yeah how
do you pull this out stops nothing there
is go back to this cool okay one thing
that's really important right now
you story container yeah so one of the
important things here is even the react
isn't gonna re-render this story because
it's already there right it's not gonna
hit that render function but is gonna
call this story so we'll go in here it's
not gonna just ignore it it's gonna go
in here and block okay well it's here
let's read mount the component and maybe
this is a quirk of reactant I'm not so
sure actually but it's gonna rerender
this component and you can see here it's
like okay if we log out the content this
story idea would expect it's been there
once and it should just be in there once
so look it should just be in there once
so if we do like to 107 sitting at once
but if I rerender you think okay well
it's gonna go get me 0 to 60 now so it
should be no twice but no react smart
nice like well you've already rendered
this component why should I go re render
again I'm not I mean I'm not gonna come
in here and say yeah I'm not gonna come
in here and say I'm gonna re render
what's the point nothing's changed
the props are the serum so I'm not going
to re-render if the props happen to be
different
I would rerender I'm not going to well
this is where some people forget that
this use effects dog
get hit and you can see that clearly
here so if you go to the network tab
search for two one zero one seven eight
or two so it's gonna do the first call
which when it gets comes on to the pit
reacts load and everything
the second once it's rendered the third
call when you do a scroll so we have to
be careful with this so one amazing
thing you can use this memo a memo works
like a maze unless all we have to do
just put memo there wrap it in a
function set story and this will prevent
that use effect being hit which is
really good because we're not making
additional additional network calls this
is one of my favorite things about the
memo function how easier well the hooks
essentially how easy it is to just
implement now and nothing is gonna come
back now and say okay well if I miss
story container and I realize this is
wrapped in a memo even I'm gonna go in
here I'm gonna check to see if that's
all really on the page and if and if
it's not exactly the same I'm not gonna
do anything why should I you know do
this twice so we'll copy this idea once
more I'll do refresh I'll close all
going here serve this serve this so
should get a network call in here now
once so it's there once if I just remove
that that you can see there's a ton in
there
I got scroll down it's gonna go rerender
and you see it's only rerender in the
new ones and it's only in that one so no
matter how much I scroll we're not gonna
be hearing that Network more than the
once because it's already there and
that's memo and it's amazing up so it'll
of memorize my favorite hook we can get
rid of that story ID don't need that
perfect clear that out do one scroll
it's not in there perfect if I do one
more turn that one's absolutely love
memo works fantastically
yeah and just reacting generals like
really good I just really enjoy working
with react and good you know don't get
to put down or be too harsh on yourself
if you don't know something like even ID
you know even people experience you've
been working react for three four or
five years or whatever it may be do
forget stuff like I just Sonny checked
myself just then to see will this
component rerender if the props haven't
changed and you can call you can call a
component to update like we've shoot
component update for the return and
we're cell returned a rear end
essentially but yeah like I start to
sanity check myself I everyone forgets
stuff so I'll get too down on yourself
if you don't you know fully understand
this tutorial I'm here help and once
where the get hubs in the link the
Twitter's in in the link the link for
github is in the description the link
for my Twitter is in the description my
email is on my youtube channel so feel
free to check that out I'll answer all
emails even though it may take me a bit
of time but I'll answer every email and
yeah just keep following these tutorials
we can run this through lighthouse now
actually I just see performance wise and
I'll show you how to do this actually
let's go ahead and do yarn build and
we'll create a production build here
creating an optimized production build
let's see let's see let's see let's see
should give us five thousand to believe
what can you serve you may have to
install let's just do like yarn I'd
serve should work there we are and you
want to run your production bill through
lighthouse buy up a new version you want
to run in incognito so you don't get
like look I mean even even he'll I've
got so much stuff that I'm trying to
learn everyone's still learning so even
on my you notice bars a certain stuff I
forget so yet don't be too hard on
yourself um click lighthouse a little
add-on you can get from the chrome store
run it in incognito so you don't get
over applications well extensions
interfering generate a nice report
let's run it in mobile mod which is nice
and you see it's responsive and born we
got 95% performance best practices time
to interactive yeah it's a bit slow
serve static assets with an effective
cache policy nothing we can do about
that unfortunately whilst we're doing it
locally but if you put on a server it
would want run great accessibility all
past best practices again we can't hit
hundred on this because we're not using
HTTP HTTP to we can do that on a server
I see a progressive web app we've got a
serviceworker run in which which is nice
we can't hit this to it Verano so but
yeah you see like we would pretty much
hit all bases you keep rerender in this
actually to get better scores the
probably one or two extensions I've got
enabled I think about like LastPass and
a few other things I've run in they 100%
100% performance it really depends but
yeah that's lighthouse and yeah I'm
really happy this awfully good project
people can learn from it's not too
complicated but yeah it's not too
complicated is there's only like warm
component in there but we're hitting API
and I'm so excited to be looking at
graph koala max it's gonna be so good to
be able you know make this from one
component renders just one API we're
gonna be hitting graph QR and getting a
bunch of different endpoints so yeah
that's pretty much it for this tutorial
hope you learned a lot we did react
testing library we did one component we
looked at memo implemented stuff like
mappers utilities 4d bound selecting
fields we had a serviceworker
we did it the eyes quite a lot actually
so if you got three of these
congratulations I'm on swear at Carl had
win all the relevant links are in the
description below this will be on github
so that will also be in the description
below follow me on youtube search my
name Carl hadwin or cognitive search and
you'll find many videos like this and
many more to come and keep an eye out
for the part two of this we're going to
be looking at graph QL that's gonna be
really really interesting and any
questions drop and below I'd love to
hear them
so yeah less as a community maybe build
on this try if you get to the graphical
point before me
fantastic maybe we can do live update
into in this article
so yeah in any ideas for all them across
I'll look to hear them thanks for
watching this video
as always I shall see you in the next
one